let's talk about neighbor well simply
and this is really
de kia die ja or de Graaf put you a
paper or de Graaf cs architecten
so what a glitch hear I broke through the
field of graff mother networks
is a way to think about mini batch
implementations die  for us
implementations are needed fullback and
people who then run run gravure networks
on your nou study for 5000 wraps
because that's one day well fitting by
jpu member
and wat graph search change the day i
change the way we think of kraft now to
networks de leeuw  week and think of
creating mini badges and that sometimes something
that week a scam the map to cross or
pencil bileam soldiers seems to me well
theo bouwman blimbing by
neighbor goeds en sound so led ricola
red led serie member soon
dig a wall networks work and  they
operate to the snow china of
computational go where jane and generate
noot in weddings
how your contractor good that i this opinion
dr great features information van de
nemer
en then you  creates a new message
and pass title
will we you can only fiduciary
men creates and introduction for that
nefarious
zero he had I takers and neighbors
takers you quickly my computer and
indicated emergency start with the individual
feature works it says the glue zero de
this  feature factors that worse get
towers forum passed to the next glue
and almost no sediment gets individuality
the transport ow to the 0th need of
interest no zero with most prediction
note ii shave that if necessary a you well
the notion rogier means this is the feature
notices there  on the emergency shiro-an for jumper
share this people who sabina layer one
representation of distress one two three en
geer agenda layer toe representation of
jot down or write down or just about the glue
in my is that I slept distress
no multiple représentations the one
for  each player and that's that's why we
need to feedback
johanna p
lemmer zero en bij links to create adhesive
and cheeks opinion as far as i want to create
glamo  ur to en bedding scrum rough
what you have the chance local view we
want oil now to create
lemon lime weddings for us because we in
c de cassini the box to create a
just by
embedding need you see such at the  idea prize
so the import and top selection is that
then layer jane and generates initiation
for the snow zero
using what god take good structure
and features a round
this grass olivine want to computer layer
the initiations of needs zero what a
medical the great structure
puddle  features of the sidewalk take
well do the nut and iconic north
travels or the count thailand not to know
the rest of the count freddy an opinion
or note about beam deep and the or gold
the count structure isb hands access
neighborhood and that's important  in
his
beacause die smit siphonophorae layer
jane en glamor to generate dan in my
thing will of need
using these got record good structure
and features
this means whole thing not to know to the
ti  me and engineering that initiation that
got some neighbor good in iping i
north rest of the network and now
we've the lines case is relatively narrow
entrepreneur good size is not to beach
which means that this is leds i constant
size
but the entire graphs die  much much
bigger take the least need a
relatively little information on their
relative you two modes to use to
generate or created jan bennink of
0-zero and the this is the my insight
the main insight is that who won a dat to
computer wants to lead  provided benoot
homini is the got recorder good
structure from that distress and i an icon
or the rest of the net be rice or the
network has not effect the embedding
of the snow to pinterest and for this
effect it is the got recorder good
all round bed never  just something wrong
that well week and generate mini badger's
in such a way that may say that simple
and different notion namibia
it makes who antonie put' who lives pot
report to the mini bed but when you
w  oning to boost tyler computations
graphs in toe de mini bikes something like
crime ipca accelerated and on kid's
got recordable good computations rough
and this is one
element in the back end and surrounded by
semper de sec and then something creates
computations power and put this  into my
minibike and so long and so for such
audi's least few apps my badger's
ruby's molenbeek was it badger's his
normal compost or individual knows
what badges her compost or network
neighbor good
badger's her compost from computations
race whoever you live or semper en
computations race
name and then put this and computations
like to see the jpu memory so that week
a computer the burden to it so mini mac
or m computations race so through
forsyth there no you well what is the kia that
yes
the kia is the trap something  pie who the
insight
that in order the computer initiation
whose kimono
discovers who is not tournament decay group
record good or webnode
so who is min seafight create a mini
batchi  ng mag base then the notes what broom
the got on neighbor good then we will
be able to computer
avb me to computer driven in 10 a
reliable oei zo this clique
rather than putting emergency shop mini
beds more putting
computational digs for another
word got recordable good  into the into
the mini beds well beacause who
broke fed to whom and there
computations grafts entire network taker
good of cake pops into the in toe the
mini-bikes week and concealer the spark
location grain indian and strategy to
train the man who parameters like  im
going to simple
led cm notes for each note 3 years by
email to stamp the entire got on
neighbor good future drink die
computations power and the via the as you
ming he said that nightmare and that
week and 14 to the mini match ball the
emergency as well there is a few computations
ras
nou die gent the complete set of
information
the need to computer initiation of
family of and rhino de in the mini bikes
zo weekend en compute  r read about the die
family badge en week a damper forum
heating costs driven in the same to basic
jan dirk de man the paramed per week
respect through the gradient
to date and mini batch read and dc's to
cast ingredient me as the badger boring and
stupid die  create ad so
the the great game to him or
random mission but so fine everyone
can participate at least bring to this were both
fixed so that the dance the ideal
so flow do it do where i
play this danny gemma
stihl fs legal notion of  mini
badger's a stick if i need training the greenhouse
for the something
who didn't get the get the entire record
good and peach so computations dig
and loaded into the cpu member
so that at least we don't just create
a lot of information just to compute one
one  fashion re-initiation for a single still
zo
computations ebx panther zo let me tell
you why it min pi x pansy
first me now experts your picos to
the deeper go de bieber this competition
graphs and this competition gr  aaf star
going to increase their size king then
chris exponentially who the the who de the
depth of the computations short of cash
here way ferdinand chris just reach
other something going to increase
exponentially who the number of layers so
that's why i show will de competition'
graff star going to get where i be if
they get very deep end in the second
thing is dat in natural graff there is
think of de lecture and talked about
microsoft instant messenger network
meetup capaldi critical tummers a crib
en this share breed i know this high
degree note that a lot of other people
connect door al had of other notes
collec conecto biceps aquino shimano
tiagra kievit built in all its need
corresponding to a large country leche
league usa to you no magic yogi
tea green is too precious so media other
one  typical relax chair and or short as
possible gunter i want to have max mother
that carney i was dahlia's moyaert
number of a typical learned
so the property is we him  that shelf emergency and
well you often had milk s degree one
million
beecher snap in gold or ordinary take your
hardware once information from one
million emergency zo discomposing gran move
get used when i quickly and you are most
likely
going to hit the schram knows where  i
have
so the point is you can now take the
entire receiver good in most of the
cases
so what do you let do do your goal is
to do is to apply a product is short
take good be good
were kia you could start the stop valve
computational graph
at cm pink at mol becoming neighbors of
and rhino
so who sat three and rhino and rhino
named three
in the competition free king program
knol is roy to worse mold atmost
age other need will in our case so buy
you through a x number
ivc let's eiji positive the majorie who
to computations count is now being to
be proved in such a way that very heavy
aggregation is going to create from
utmost to an der noot saw you
bring die sentire and she won't on  je cut out and
you know some other no time to be cut
out elsewhere and what is wrong is that
again computations rag mini maxi more
manageable bicos who gives just the
money forget then you go things that gram
lead why not to take a fix  number of
something takers in the congregation so the
property is that i have a new the sprint
computation a grave the more efficient
computer needs one
so well keep you doing is computational
free and sound right to basic lydia no
is for never for henry
layer  forever internet needed the or the
competition graff who you want to give it
to is basically computer got on
neighbor good but from the starting emergency
and then for henry 0 tenths computation
count you willing to peak had the most
crazy random numbers on andy
smith throat  air jane and who in my utmost the
product of
the age sweet 0 tenths computation a
crab heavy computations grave would stink
broccoli to grow exponentially what the
what the point again who that
d  yard and old wimpie wibi upper bounded by
age
zo the degroof bambi bed bent orbeck stuck
in the steam gamer to go quite
deep anal lettie mae cup you
primark somebody's chest strap marquis that
this de resigns but in gamma the
neighbors louis sample
ride smaller age  nothing to murmur
efficient meber good than creation week
as computational rhapsodies moller
martin wie sites in more unstable
training who chose via the glow rings and
tougher
bag parts of the network when they're
doing glass each other editions all our
gradient estimates may be more pretty
sit in hyar
work on other thing is that interesting
computations time
entrepreneur are good quite the site or the
computational graff if he are that
study exponential who is the respect to
the number of players
what is x is still the deadlines and which
dongle too deep looked interesting  i think
so now my manager
rich in will je well and in one more layer
then the
toe by jane and mix the computation age
times more expens  ive and now i know
dear ducks may be an order of five
tot en en looked
anyway line or north or do you still want 5
plus meines think you can still keep
doing this end and the last the last
importing there people live there is mark
number 3  hours this with a produce a
lot of freedom house
they imposed the need stamping and so
far until he could not there and stupid sampling
crunchers uniforms random
pick-up aids takers or active never what
the us be the juice red is that here for
an app works gp highly skilled and the
green solutions
so this is already had or can you still see single
single notes our love the rhino the
network and review where
peking ganapati my old friend there is
a simple
age of its neighbors your most likely
king door  sample this lack the green
man nam was there perhaps the most
import and nosing the network and p'raps
very nicely to the muslim shapes
this could be users that the emergency lines
games the ski slopes of content that there is not
very important e  n you don't do well
single
so what you can do and this kind of mindset
is practically that your dollar and then
what we three start the needs of
interest geer degree 0 and when you're
sampling strategy is the p age
neighbors but not  let in at random wat
based on their
random accu 3 start score sweet miss that
that in layer
you're going to take it most important
nemer
of a new note en de bies mins en that
you de count your phone to select we die
kan  still much more i present dat die much
better connected and any two happy to be
busy die smoor important notes and offers
no better more i live for feature
information design more active users zo
dean of provider more information for
predictions
zo in practice the strategy of sampling
de computations graf
works much better and the rod resizing
geert pcb design to do a proper in west
idea thing about how will you die fine
wake different strategies to say more
to the fine de computations gratis
sample de computa  tions graphs and go what
therein strategies in which time of
cases sighting the bull hasn't been
systematically most chain what bags
time i could be very important for the
fourth day
digger i lay so to summarize the
products take are good latch approach
the idea is  that the computational
graphic contract for each emergency and the
computational cruiser putin to the
mini mini batch the cash cumpilation a
count scan that can be very big work mercury
in shinga you go those three rickety meber
good who take damper bunch are
good white we became  computational
graphical cry the couple castile
origin so upsampling to increase
computational
chelsea something us so in christ the
martyrs basles de channel by jane and
architect cherise
couple closet i even prayed something unequal
already shapes or dropout if you do not think
of idac2
and the computer hour  pumpkin
computationally like keys to generate
distress embedded to shirk
kelly it's that easy to your network
jane and n  ummer om jane and comments were
deep
this competition graz may still be kan
large which means you're bad guys who
left to be smaller and which means and
you're a
upgrade and maybe am i can still possible
lessons reallifesoap
love websites is beautiful de  the gradient
is lessons reliable and
in the proenings is too much game game
the gradient gradients arno to realize
something like this import and to find a good balance
between the bad guys and the pruning factor
or sampling factor for the
computational marius and sylla biodesign
this is really like  it say what most of
the boot child astral implementation sap
power mother networks use to actually
scaling up do you there in size cross
for jumper black used on
pinterest
ali baba en sola